and seeing us we're down fourth-of-july
quickly approaching I thought I'd lead
off with some thoughts on America's
founding principles for us this morning
the United States was the first nation
established on the premise that govern
exist to protect our god-given
unalienable rights oh I'll have more to
say about that in just a couple weeks
you know it was a it was a revolutionary
idea we shouldn't forget that as we talk
about these complex foreign policy
issues the idea of government for the
people by the people was and remains
important and was unique we're always
striving for a more perfect union we
don't get it right every day we try to
improve them we use our unmatched power
to protect rights at home and abroad
happy early fourth of July evil into
your families now turning to the
substance of my remarks today and I want
talk about one of the world's most
unfree countries yesterday the Chinese
Communist Party implemented its
draconian national security law on Hong
Kong in violation commitments that it
made to the Hong Kong people and to the
United Kingdom in a UN registered treaty
and in contravention of Hong Kongers
human rights and fundamental freedoms
free Hong Kong was one of the world's
most stable prosperous and dynamic
cities now that will be just another
communist Ron city where its people will
be subject to the party elites whims
it's sad indeed this is already
happening security forces are already
rounding up on Congress for daring to
speak and think if really the rule of
law has been eviscerated and as always
the Chinese Communist Party 2/3 its own
people more than anything else the
United States is deeply concerned about
the lost sweeping permissions and the
safety of everyone living in the
territory including Americans article 38
of the new law also purports to apply to
offenses committed outside of Hong Kong
by non-residents of Hong Kong and this
likely includes Americans this is
outrageous and an affront to all nations
on Friday we implemented visa
restrictions on those responsible for
the hong kong crackdown
Monday we announced that we would end
defense equipment and dual use
technology exports of us original going
to the territory we will continue to
implement president Trump's directive to
end Hong Kong's
special status other federal agencies
are involved as well I applaud FCC
Chairman Ajit PI's for destiny
designating Huawei and ZTE as national
security risks we're also continuing to
take action to build on president Trump
signing of the Weger Human Rights Policy
Act today the United States Department
of State
along with Treasury Commerce and DHS go
issuing a business advisory to companies
with supply chain links to entities
complicit in forced labor and other
human rights abuses and Xinjiang and
throughout China CEOs should read this
notice closely and be aware of the
reputation economic and legal risks of
supporting such assaults on human
dignity I want to call attention to
recent credible and deeply disturbing
new reports that the Chinese Communist
Party is imposing forced sterilization
and abortions on wiggers and other
minorities in western China this
shocking news is said consistent with
the ccp's decades-long callous disregard
for the sanctity of human life the call
on all nations women's advocates
religious groups and human rights
organizations to stand up for the
Chinese people's basic human dignity
look the Chinese feminist party
brutality affects the rest of the world
- we welcome India's ban on a certain
mobile apps the conservative appendages
of the CCP's surveillance state India's
clean app approach will boost India's
sovereignty will also boost India's
integrity and national security as the
Indian government self itself has stated
today Canada's National Day celebrations
are dimmed by the ccp's recent decision
to bring trumped-up espionage charges
against michael korvac and michael spa
burn the ccp's propagandist have implied
these two Canadian citizens are hostages
held in retaliation for Canada's lawful
arrest of huawei's executive
she is charged by the Department of
Justice with bank fraud wire fraud and
conspiracy to commit bank and wire fraud
I commend the Canadian government for
standing firm in backing their
independent legal system hostage-taking
for political gains which china in
league with the iran's and Venezuela's
of the world the two mics need to come
home now in the Middle East at the
forced Brussels conference on Syria
yesterday the United States announced
almost 700 million dollars in
humanitarian assistance to support
Syrians inside the country and displaced
abroad bringing our total funding to
just over eleven point three billion
dollars since the conflict began more
than nine years ago in Iraq I want to
commend the government there for
bringing all armed groups under its
control including those firing rockets
at Iraq II government facilities the
presence of these lawless actors remains
the single biggest obstacle to
additional assistance or economic
investment for the country for the world
to help Iraq Iraq must first help itself
Baghdad's actions are a step in the
right direction and we applaud what
about three brutal honor killings that
have taken place in Iran 14-year old
Romina Ashraf II 19 your Fatemeh Farhi
at 22 year old Ronnie Emery two were
beheaded and one was beaten to death
with an iron bar at the hands of
relatives for 40 years
corrupt Iranian leaders have condoned
murder dehumanized women and ignored
cries for justice when will they stop
this unspeakable wicked assault on human
dignity staying in Iran as many of you
saw yesterday I spoke with the UN
Security Council urging them to retain
the 13-year old arms embargo on Iraq
these restrictions as a result of the
failed jcpoa set to expire in October if
it's allowed to buy weapons from the
likes of China and Russia more civilians
in the Middle East will died at the
hands of the regime in its proxies it's
that straightforward Tehran will become
an arms deal for the Maduro and Assad's
of the world
sworn enemies of Israel Micah massa
Hezbollah will be better armed your
European nations will be put at risk the
team was put together a short video that
explains why this is so important I like
to show it to you now
[Music]
so when you all hear about legal
niceties and complexities and intra
international fighting about what the
right course of action is remind
yourself about what happens to the world
if this arms embargo is lifted in the
end that's what matters in the end is
what the UN Security Council has the
capacity to ensure does not take place I
remind you to go back and look at
remarks from the previous administration
about the fact that the United States
has the unambiguous right without the
consent of any other nation to ensure
that this arms embargo stays in place
this administration to do everything we
can to make sure that that happens to
keep not only American people safe but
to reduce instability in the Middle East
the veronik we applaud this week's
constitutional reform in the Republic of
Georgia we call on Georgia's Parliament
to honor the will of the Georgian people
and pledges of Georgian officials
through the passage and implementation
of internationally recommended election
reforms I've put on them
and yesterday for the third time in less
than a year I met with my counterparts
from Kazakhstan Kyrgyz Republic
chicest and Turkmenistan Uzbekistan in
the c5 plus one format we share many
goals including peace in Afghanistan
strengthening regional trade energy and
security ties and building resilient
economies for each of those countries as
a sign of America's focused on building
gender and partnerships our Development
Finance Corporation CEO and a Buller is
today accompanying ambassador kalilas on
a trip to the region to scout out
investment opportunities where American
businesses can be successful and help
these countries be sovereign and
independent as well relations are in
order for the Democratic Republic of
Congo in an unrest unprecedented ruling
president Shashi today's chief of staff
was convicted for corruption and no one
however high in office should be above
the law
and last week the people of Malawi
elected Lazarus Chuck where as their
next president this is only the second
time the second time that a court had
second time that in America in Africa
rather that a court has overturned a
presidential election tainted by her
regularities in the only time that a
reelection process has resulted in an
election of an opposite party candidate
truly a historic opportunity through the
people of that country this past week
the United States and Russia held the
first round of nuclear arms control
talks our two sides met in Vienna that
positive detailed discussions on a wide
range of topics including China's
secretive build-up Beijing regrettably
boycotted the talks continuing its
record of secrecy and rejection of
multilateralism and on Monday the bureau
of energy resources led an interagency
working group as part of the u.s. greets
a strategic dialogue where we're working
together to diversify energy sources in
Southeast Europe develop resources
together and promote regional energy
security and finally to our hemisphere
all 2100 is member states voted last
week to condemn the Maduro regime's
attempts to suppress independent
political parties in Venezuela our
region has categorically rejected the
attempts to create a phony Maduro
friendly opposition the United States
also congratulate the people of Suriname
in their elections at a peaceful
transition of power to a new National
Assembly we look forward to working with
that new government in contrast it's now
been four months since Ghana's election
long past due for a peaceful transition
of power CARICOM and the OAS have
certified the recount results should get
on with it I've instructed my department
ensure those who undermined Yama's
democracy are held accountable also
today the USMC it comes into effect it
will open up new opportunities for US
Mexico and Canadian business and
consumers a good news finally a book in
my remarks by marking another
anniversary to July 1st marked the 70th
anniversary of the fulbright Thailand
American educational programs and
cultural programs the world like this
underscore America's respect for freedom
democracy decency and respect for human
rights and with that I'm happy to take
thank you I have one on the arms in
Florida I was curious if the u.s. is
willing to accept accept a temporary
extension to potentially get Russia
China to go along with it
that's hoping you could get into the
specifics of what terms are acceptable
and on the larger nuclear violations
that the US and now the IAEA have
identified are we looking at a menu of
options for repercussions for this and
specifically my snapback be one of those
options on the menu I was hoping you
could touch on that specifically because
it seems some are making the argument
that snapback accounts for the arms
embargo and of course all other
restrictions it's open you could talk
about that a bit so first of all our
objective is not to extend the arms
embargo for another short period of time
that's how we got into this mess right
the arms embargo should be lifted when
the Islamic Republic around begins to
behave in a way that is consistent with
the ability to move arms around the
world to purchase to act in a way that's
consistent with the way normal nations
act so it's it's a it's not a
time-limited matter it's a
conditions-based matter and our
objective is to make sure that the
lifting of that arms embargo is
condition space and when the time is
right
happy to let it happen tomorrow but
extending it for six months or a year or
two years fundamentally falls into the
same trap that the previous
administration fell into I know there's
a bit of a striving argument what if you
got twenty years but if you got fifty
years what have you got a hundred years
I don't want to talk about anything
specific what our objective is very
clearly to say that the lifting of that
arms embargo is not appropriate until
such time as the world can be sure these
folks won't use those weapons systems or
the money that flows from the sale of
those weapon systems for malign purposes
as for the other provisions what's
happening at the IAEA
make sure everybody's up to speed the IE
file report has made very clear that the
Iranians have failed to allow access to
to sites that are suspected of
potentially having engaged in nuclear
activities related to their previous
programs programs that create the jcpoa
Iranians continue to deny access to the
IAEA this is not about the jcpoa this is
about an NPT framework the safeguards
provisions that every nuclear power
signs up for and that the Iranians have
agreed to this is outside and separate
from the jcpoa it's never been the case
before that a regime has denied access
to the IAEA and so yes in terms of our
thinking about responding
we hope the world will see that this is
a serious risk to the entire
non-proliferation regime and the United
States is prepared to lead to come up
with responses to this which would be
appropriate and consistent with practice
protecting and preserving that regime
against Iranian intransigence that is
entirely appropriate hope the ratings
will change there might a lot fall I EA
EA unfettered repeated consistent access
today they chosen not to do so Straits
Times and in remarks about a week ago at
the process forum you mentioned a review
of American resources abroad false
postures and so forth
reordering could you tell us a little
bit more about that and specifically
does the indo-pacific a nation in
particular figure in that so all these
specifics about force posture to
secretary expert but there's important
foreign policy ramifications how we
think about resource allocation how we
secure American freedom and so this is
something that's been going on frankly
since the national security strategy was
laid down at roughly the beginning
outset of the administration and so we
have consistently been looking for not
only how we deploy our forces Department
of Defense Forces but all of the assets
that we have how do we think about our
cyber capability how do we think about
where our embassies out of eat so we
have the State Department's undergone
any parallel process of thinking about
how do we engage diplomatically where do
we need to be where do we need about our
resource as well so this has been a
broad national security strategic review
that's thinking about how do we focus on
the threat
that challenged us today and not those
the challenges 10 or 20 or 30 years ago
and then as your question suggested we
have certainly raised our game with
respect to thinking about the threat
that the Chinese Communist Party poses
to the United States of America you will
see that resources and strategy will be
the result of the objective the
president Trump laid out yesterday
following speech and the Security
Council the German representative said
they are a US has no standing in this
meaning to invoke UN sanctions and by
doing so you will be violating the
international how do you comment on that
and to what extent would that's not back
be efficient if it is not supported by
your allies are usually European allies
so two things that I don't want to get
into the legal analysis you're
suggesting we have the full authority to
go exercise that right as a participant
in UN Security Council resolution 2231
we are highly confident we have the
right to exercise that it is not our
first objective we hope that the UN
Security Council the Chinese the
Russians every partner there will see
that it is in their best interest to
deny Iran this benefit that comes when
they've not changed the behavior one
lick and so so we're hopeful that we'll
be able to do this without having to go
through a complex difficult process at
the UN so that's our certainly our
objective and we think we think we'll
prevail we think as we get closer the
world will see if you're a citizen
living in Brussels or you're someone in
Athens do you really want the Iranian
regime to have Chinese fighter planes I
don't think so I think I think the
government will conclude the same thing
if you're if you're sitting in Finland
and you're trying to sort your way
through about whether it's a good idea
for the Russians to be able to have
another partner do they sell weapons oh
I think these countries I think each
nation will conclude this is a bad idea
they will regret that the jcpoa allow
this to expire and they'll join us in
this it is certainly a full-fledged
diplomatic effort that we're engaged in
to convince the world that this is the
right outcome not just for the United
States
go talk to our partners in Saudi Arabia
or the Emirates and Kuwait they know too
that if Iran has be allowed to become an
arms merchant again instability in the
Middle East will flow this bounty issue
you had some conversations with senior
Russian officials after your aides were
told about evidence of the Russian
bounties did you use those opportunities
to tell Moscow not to endanger US troops
in that manner so a lot of what you said
suggests no I don't think you actually I
don't want to comment I'm on the
intelligence the CIA's put out a
statement the DNI has put out a
statement but I can tell you the
intelligence community handled this
incredibly well we see threats in
intelligence reporting to our soldiers
stationed all over the world every
single day every single day and so I can
assure you that whatever reporting it is
that you're referring to that we
responded in precisely the correct way
with respect to making sure that our
forces were postured appropriately that
they were aware of the level of the
credibility of the threat and that we
were there secondly the fact that the
Russians are engaged in Afghanistan in a
way that's adverse to the United States
is nothing new by the way some members
of Congress are out there today
suggesting that they are shocked and
appalled by this they saw the same
intelligence that we saw so it would be
interesting to ask them what they did
when they saw whatever intelligence is
that they are referring to
it would have been access to this
information as well not just the
intelligence committees by the way even
more broadly than that we took this
seriously we handle it appropriately the
Russians have been selling small arms
that it put Americans at risk there for
10 years we've objected to it to your
point when I meet with my Russian
counterparts I talk with them about this
each time stop this we think we have a
not perfect but somewhat overlapping
objective in Afghanistan is on their
doorstep we know they were routed in
Afghanistan right so they they have an
objective there to to reduce the risk of
terrorism there so yes
maybe not every time but with great
frequency when I speak to my Russian
counterparts we talk about Afghanistan
we talk about the fact that we don't
want them engaged in this but it's to do
just so everybody could be level set
money flowing to Afghanistan to support
the Taliban has been going on since we
went to Afghanistan we're now almost two
decades ago it's not just the Russians
indeed probably not majority of the
Russians money's flowed from lots of
places from Iran even today the ratings
continue to undermine what we're trying
to accomplish in terms of peace and
reconciliation in Afghanistan it's it's
incredibly important that you take in
context how it is this recording is
developed and how it is the United
States has respond to this we do
everything we can and this president has
been vicious in securing American
freedom and protecting American soldiers
the last point there's some suggestion
somehow that there was an appropriate
response day because this was Russia if
you have 20 minutes I will read to you
what this administration has done with
respect to Russia but instead I'll just
provide it to you for the record but it
starts with a 700 billion dollar
allocation of resources department
events it continues with withdrawal from
the INF something the Russians remain
unhappy about what we've done in Syria
to push back against them including
against the vogner group this
administration has taken seriously the
threat from Russia I only wish we had
not had so much to clean up from the
previous administration's work to allow
Russia to get on the ground in Syria
make enormous gains interfere in
elections in the United States of
America under the previous
administration's watch we've had a lot
to clean up and president Trump has been
serious about responding to this in a
way that protects America keeps
Americans safe and every day working
diligently make sure that we keep our
soldiers safe wherever any threat
whether that's from Russia or otherwise
otherwise presents itself with the
Bounty's escalation
wouldn't the bounties be an escalation
go ahead
Thank You Morgan Thank You mr. secretary
my question is you just mentioned about
the report written by dr. Adrienne sands
regarding the forces sterilization and
abortion of the Rieger population there
by China assimilating the weaker people
in the report actually dr. sands he
presented compelling evidence that the
Chinese government severe human rights
violation of the weaker people meet the
criteria of genocide as defined by the
UN Convention on the genocide and also a
phoner Hong Kong Governor Chris Patten
called China's policy toward witnesses
also genocide in addition to that
European Parliament share mine heart
beautiful and his first vice chair
Evelyne Gebhardt
in their joint statement yesterday also
said the report further elaborate the
assessment that we may be witnessing the
implementation of genocide I know you
also issued a statement regarding this
report so do you believe China is
committing genocide or Zwicker people
United States taking the strongest
action of any nation in the world to
protect the human rights of all Chinese
people including the weaker people will
continue to do that I hope our European
allies allies in the region will take
this as seriously we help other Muslim
nations will take this seriously as well
and respond in a way that has the
opportunity to protect those people's
human rights we'll evaluate how we think
about the Chinese actions and what it is
we ought to call them we've we've worked
closely with Congress to pass
legislation legislation that if I recall
correctly passed nearly unanimously on
Capitol Hill President signed that
legislation the United States takes
seriously our obligation to preserve
human rights human rights of the people
in China we'll continue to do that we're
constantly evaluating those actions
against the legal norms and standards
for the world
um given all that you just a doubt about
the threat from Russia is now the time
to be bringing Russia back into the g7
and and if I may on Hong Kong obviously
China has passed the national security
law and the punitive measures that have
been taken so far don't appear to have
prevented them and taking these actions
so how far is the u.s. willing to go and
are you willing to take the mandatory
actions laid out a mandatory sanctions
laid out in the Hong Kong economy act
well if the manager will do it we always
comply with a lot here to take part
right what we do and so we will
absolutely implement those laws both
consistent with the letter in the spirit
of what those detectors require so we
will certainly do that and there is more
work to do for sure but in the end in
the end general secretary gets to make
the decision about whether he wants to
move this nation closer to something
that is disconnected from the world the
most fundamental base they talked about
when I was in Honolulu they talked about
wanting to be good stewards
international players that comply with
multilateral obligations but when you're
violating citizens most fundamental
freedoms we should look to your actions
not to words and so that's what we will
continue to do we'll continue to do all
the things that we can and importantly
we will continue to build out a global
coalition that understands the challenge
the Chinese Communist Party threat
places on freedom-loving peoples all
across the world this isn't a us-china
challenge this is a challenge that is
between freedom and authoritarianism and
so long as we keep that foremost in our
minds I'm confident that freedom-loving
peoples of the world will prevail with
respect to Russia in the g7 but when
they were in this they were causing
problems they're out of it and they
still continue to present risk to us we
need to talk to the Russians and so
president gets to decide if he wants to
become the summits or not that's his
decision all certainly left him but I do
believe it is absolutely important that
we have more frequent engagement of the
Russians you saw we had two days in
Vienna last week to talk about
we're really critical strategic dialogue
about nuclear weapon systems
proliferating around the world I think
it is wholly important and appropriate
for the United States that continue to
have dialogue with the Russians to
convince them to change some of the
activities that are inconsistent with
what it is the United States needs to do
to preserve security and freedom for its
own people you don't want to get into
the specifics of this intelligence but
now that it is been I don't want you I
won't because I'm not gonna further
jeopardize intelligence capabilities I'm
not gonna put at risk the young men and
women of Afghanistan in the same way
that some of news organizations have
done I just simply won't engage in their
colleagues it's inappropriate it is
dangerous and you want not be part of
that as a former CIA director and
soldier however do you feel that the
president should have been told about
the Russian bounty being offered to the
Taliban to kill US troops even if that
was not fully verified intelligence you
have six things in your question there
that are just I'm not gonna go there
you've got assumptions about things that
that just don't don't reflect what it is
that we've actually seen and done with
respect to this idea visit this
administration has been good and when I
would say a director I was directly
involved in this and making sure that
the President had the relevant
information you need to make important
strategic decisions you should know the
threats I'll give you an example of
threats to our embassy every morning I
get a briefing it's my first or second
thing I do every day about challenges
that we have threats to our embassy I
don't share that with the president
every day these are Americans these are
State Department diplomats who's whose
are at risk what we do is we do the hard
work we put our team on the ground and
make sure we have the security posture
right if necessary I call my counterpart
of the partner defense and make sure
that his forces are properly positioned
if the threat is a verifiable enough and
of a sufficient threat we do this every
day
we make those judgments that's my
responsibility to do that to do it well
when the threat is sufficiently serious
the scale of the threat is of such
ports that there's an action that I
think that the president needs to be
aware of and the information that I've
seen is sufficiently credible then we
make sure that the president is aware of
that the president has been consistently
aware of the challenges that Russia
presents to us and he is aware of the
risk in Afghanistan it's why we have
spent so much time over this past year
at the president's direction to reduce
risk to our forces in Afghanistan in a
way no previous administration has done
who said about a peace and
reconciliation plan inside of it and by
the way as part of that we've talked to
the Russians about how we can reduce the
risk of violence from the Taliban to
Americans on the ground in Afghanistan
know we've we've taken the threat and
the president's taking the threat to our
forces in Afghanistan incredibly serious
throughout the entire duration of this
administration the president didn't need
to know about this intelligence Thank
You mr. secretary
my question is on Lebanon that when is
judge who issued a ruling banning lawful
and foreign journalists from
interviewing the US ambassador to Beirut
submitted with the resignation yesterday
after he was effective judicial
inspection over the ruling is they were
satisfied with that and are you
concerned of any military escalation
between Israel and Hezbollah in the near
future
we're always concerned about space
between Hezbollah and Israel but related
to this incident with our ambassador and
her ability speak freely there that
doesn't raise my concerns greatly I
don't think that greatly increases the
risk of conflict between the two as for
this judge no longer being the judge one
fewer Hezbollah judge is always a good
thing
secretary you just mentioned you talked
about having talked to the Russians
about reducing threats to American
service people in from the Taliban and
yet ok from various but you know if
indeed they were offering the Russians
are offering bounties yes indeed yes ok
you know I'm just you all you all are
going places I'm not gonna go because we
have we have work that is important to
keep our soldiers safe and I'm not gonna
allow you to lay down questions with
facts that are certain and say oh he
didn't refute what I said in my question
therefore it must be true I'm not gonna
okay but this would seem a major
escalation and you've talked about your
rant and every time Iran would would
attack American troops through their
proxies there would be consequences to
pay and so I'm just wondering if that
same kind of warning should not be given
to the Russians I can assure you I can
absolutely show you them we see serious
credible threats from the Russians
whether there's our Russians engaged in
threatening activity in Ukraine Russians
gauged in threatening activity in Syria
Russian threatening activity there now
in Libya their actions in Venezuela the
list is long when we see credible
information that suggests that the
Russians are putting American lives at
risk we're responding in a way that it's
serious news that do we do we warn them
do we talk to them I think we sure the
answer is of course we do I'm Hong Kong
in your opening remarks you called it
now after the security law was imposed
just another city subjected to the ccp's
winds on is hong kong lost and how far
is this administration willing to go to
try to prevent that or to try to bring a
situation back to to where it once was
well whether it's lost or not is
entirely dependent upon the decisions
that general secretary she makes and
when you say lost you mean as they lost
its freedom insisted is it no longer an
autonomous place I assigned a
certification a couple weeks back now
that suggested that it was not I suppose
these things are always reversible the
actions of the last 48 hours
that the Chinese government at least at
this point the Chinese Communist Party
has no intention of reversing that trend
and as for how far we'll go I'll just
repeat what the president said I wants
to ensure with a handful of exceptions
that Hong Kong is treated just like
mainland China because that's the way
the general secretary she has chosen to
treat that place as well with that thank
you all I've got ahead on today
thank you all have a good day